(gentle music)
- Prior to the pandemic,
we had a full house.
It was wall-to-wall people
in here all the time.
And then on March 16th, we closed,
and we have had no customers
in here since then.
- [Narrator] In mid-March,
Gleason's boxing gym,
like gyms and fitness
centers across the country,
closed because of the pandemic.
Now after roughly half a year on pause,
Gleason's is preparing
to re-open its doors.
- Instead of coming in at your whim,
you have to come in
through appointment only,
and the employees will all
have to have a COVID-19 test.
Everybody that walks in
will have to immediately
use hand sanitizer.
We'll also take their temperature.
- [Narrator] New York State
has provided gym owners
with 35 pages of protocols
they'll have to follow
if they wanna reopen.
But it still isn't clear
what the new normal for
gyms will look like.
Will clients return to their old routines,
or will the pandemic have a lasting impact
on our workout habits?
Simply put, how might
the coronavirus pandemic
transform the fitness industry?
(gentle music)
The American fitness industry
has been upended by COVID-19.
24 Hour Fitness and Gold's Gym
filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy
after missing out on membership dues.
The parent company of
New York Sports Clubs
and Lucille Roberts gyms
have also warned of
potential bankruptcies.
- COVID-19 pandemic has
created severe shock
to this industry, to operators.
This is industry that derive
majority of the revenue
from monthly membership, right?
So one, the gyms were forced
to close in mid-March.
The revenue stream had gone.
It was really zero revenue coming in,
while you still have
huge lease obligations,
as well as the labor cost.
So the company, all of a
sudden, went into severe stress.
- [Narrator] According to O'Brien,
before the pandemic,
many chains borrowed heavily
to expand aggressively.
- The insurers that
cover a majority of them
are owned by private equity firms,
and the private equity
firms are smart money,
and they're attracted to industry
for two reasons primarily.
Number one is the recurring
nature of the membership.
You have a very reliable,
steady stream of monthly
revenue coming in;
and number two, there is this long-term,
fundamental demographic shift,
a focus of fitness and wealth.
As much as we think
that people go to gyms,
that, in terms of percentage of people
actually belonging to gym memberships,
it's still in the low 20% for the US.
So there's still a huge growth trend.
- [Narrator] But the pandemic
has changed the math.
- You're stuck with very expensive leases
that worked in the old time,
but doesn't really work in the new normal.
It's a huge problem.
- [Narrator] One gym that has been spared
the worst of the pandemic
is Planet Fitness,
the biggest chain in the country.
- There's not many other
businesses out there
that through this had zero
revenue since we shut down.
There's not takeout food,
there's no delivery service.
This whole industry had zero revenue.
You know, luckily, we're franchise system,
lotta sophisticated franchisees,
multi-store operators,
which has really helped us.
They might have five,
10, or 25 plus stores
in multiple states,
which has also helped us.
We might have some
closed in New York still,
but have clubs in Florida that
have been open for a while,
so it's really helped
us along through this.
(gentle music)
- [Announcer] A chance to grow stronger.
- [Narrator] One of
the few areas of growth
in the fitness industry
during the pandemic
has been at-home classes.
With gyms closed, many Americans scrambled
to create their own at-home gyms,
leading to a shortage of equipment
like kettlebells and rowing machines.
(gentle inspirational music)
(woman gasps)
- [Woman] A Peleton?
- [Trainer] Give it up
for our first time riders.
- All right, first ride.
- The other part of the industry trend
we've seen in the last few years
is technology is really
transforming this industry.
It started with companies like Peleton.
About a few years ago,
they started offering at-home.
You can buy a Peleton bike,
and pay a monthly subscription, about $40,
and have access to their on-demand
as well as live classes.
So this pandemic with
the lockdown measures,
stay at home measures, remote working,
we've accelerated this
at home workout trend.
- I mean, home fitness is not new.
It's been here since Richard
Simmons and Jane Fonda.
Then it was Tae Bo with Billy Blanks,
and then it was P90X,
that it's always been here.
I do, however, think
that this has accelerated
the adoption of digital,
whether it's in-club or out-of-club,
I think people now realize
that they can utilize this
and learn how to exercise better,
get the most of their
membership in-club and at home.
(gentle music)
- Back in Brooklyn,
Bruce Silverglade remains
committed to Gleason's,
despite the challenges
he's faced during lockdown.
- The pandemic has taken
a tremendous toll on me,
emotionally and physically.
The monthly expense
has been about $36,000.
The monthly income has been zero.
So the only that I've
been able to stay afloat
is to use some of my personal monies
and to borrow money from the bank.
And this has been
something that is new
to me and to Gleason's.
Prior to the pandemic,
I was debt-free.
Big expense, again, was
my rent and my payroll.
Other than that, I had no bills.
And now, when this is over
and I get back to business,
(clears throat) I'm probably
gonna have a $200,000 debt.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Despite Gleason's
being a small, independent gym,
Silverglade is confident it will survive.
But few independent
gyms are like Gleason's.
The Brooklyn-based boxing gym
is one of the best known
boxing gyms in the country,
if not the world.
- I don't wanna get sick, okay?
I'm 74 years old,
I have diabetes.
So there's no way in the world
I wanna have people come in here
and inflict COVID-19 on anyone or on me.
Gleason's will not close,
I won't allow it to close.
But I'm gonna have a huge debt.